hey you guys it's the movie
retrospective man i'm not in the [ __ ]
thing i'm very now i'm in the video
i was in the other video here in another
video yeah the video next
yeah all right yeah so hi everybody and
tom land
that's how it works that's how the
internet works when i'm involved
yeah that that that
way i show up in the other video on
youtube
one next
[Laughter]
i don't even remember what movie it was
but some people seem to
really respond to us doing more kind of
like 50s sci-fi type movies and so i put
that in the poll uh i put this movie in
the poll and it handily won and i'm glad
because i've been wanting to do this for
a really long time because i had not
seen this movie since i was a kid and i
really really wanted to revisit it this
is the 1954 sci-fi classic
them yeah and i'll tell you what
i mentioned this on the other program
that's what made jenny go up there and
get a vote on it
this is my dad's favorite movie when he
was a kid all right
when he was a kid he said this movie
scared the [ __ ] out of him
and then later on when he saw alien and
aliens
he said man you know what i mean
he's like this is like them the movie
them
someone watched it last night because i
haven't seen this movie in a long time
i watched it last night
and alien and them is an homage to this
movie a lot of scenes a lot of concepts
are directly out of it
um this movie yeah and it's obvious when
you watch it
yeah this was a very very influential uh
sci-fi film yeah it definitely
influenced aliens for sure uh there's
some scenes in here that are direct
homages i think it also um particularly
the one character like the the older
doctor
i think he kind of influenced the
character uh the older doctor guy in uh
the scientist in jurassic park um so
like the just his this sort of like
daughtering genius there's another
version of newt in this
yeah pretty much yeah
uh the
the scene where dallas in aliens is
going through the round tubes with the
with a flashlight and a flame thrower
trying to hunt down the trying to look
for the alien is
is directly from this movie the hero in
this movie is doing that same thing and
you're going oh alien yeah
that's why the whole idea of going to
the egg chamber to find the [ __ ]
queen and the drones and the [ __ ]
eggs and the [ __ ] hatching and the
outbreak spreading around and it's gonna
wipe out the earth that that all
that's all stuff taught later homaged in
aliens you mean you know when you see it
you go okay and the sp the thing is is
that
usually in a 1950s movie
the special effects suck
and it's mostly old dudes old white
dudes seven or eight of them sitting
around in offices talking to each other
on the phone that's most of the damn
movie yeah not this one
this one does have some of that every
50s movie takes place at office yeah but
they do leave the office and then they
go on little missions and they fight the
bugs and they go places and hear
people's story about seeing the bugs
flying and
it's good it's real good uh uh if for
for 1950s it's high budget and
action-packed
the the weapons and the troops are
authentic i think some on some shots i
believe it was us army or national guard
yeah well the particularly the last
iconic scene with the fight with the um
flame throwers those were absolutely
like real like flamethrowers real
flamethrowers well they were real
flamethrowers and the dudes that were
army guys they were army guys doing it
yeah and there actually are burning up
the giant ants
all right now i remembered that when
they were shooting up from a kid i
remember when they were shooting up the
damn ants out in the desert with a tommy
gun i remember seeing bullet holes
appeared in it
and
looking back on it i thought it was live
rounds that says man that had to have
been live round so they were shooting
that thing uh saw it again last night no
it's not it's not but it looks really
good
uh so it is blanks that they're shooting
except for the uh
the flame throwers
and they also uh bring out some some of
the newer late world war ii bazookas
there's a rocket launcher
and they were shooting white phosphorus
rounds
and uh that's real white phosphorus
that's that's the real thing so they're
not
they're not
cheapening out with this movie this is
good [ __ ] good [ __ ]
um and it's effective it's got
a lot of tension and it's like wow
what's going to happen you know it's
it's still a great movie it holds up
it's 50 style
but yeah yeah it's 50 i mean if you're
into like creature features yeah i feel
like this is one of the ones that you
kind of have to see because this wasn't
the first you know 50s sci-fi
this was the first big bug movie that
wasn't the first like irradiated giant
monster one that would have been i'm
pretty sure that was beast of uh beast
from twenty thousand thousand fathoms
which came out the year before this one
but that was like a big like godzilla s
kind of monster whereas this was the
first of the big bug movies and i feel
like also this is one that was from a
major studio yeah warner brothers where
a lot of the other ones were kind of
like more independently produced and
were a lot cheaper now this one they
cheaped out on this one too which i'll
get into in a little bit
but this was a major studio that
released it was a big hit um it was
actually one of their highest earners
warner brothers for 1954 either their
highest earners or among their highest
earners that year
so this was like a massive hit i think
what makes this one stand out from other
50s because it does have some of the
same things that you expect from a 50s
sci-fi
a lot of talk like military scientists
all talking about like thinking about
how we're going to solve the the giant
monster
[ __ ] to you the audience explain yeah
hold yeah whole whole uh there's
actually a mini documentary explained to
you about how ants work yeah but those
which i kind of liked that actually i
didn't mind it it's it's 1950s yeah
everything is very 50 style they assume
you're either a child or for or that you
don't know anything
yeah which i either one would work they
were very authoritative yes like we're
gonna tell you some [ __ ] it's like
you're watching a government training
film at certain times
everything's the authorities are
explaining [ __ ] to you you dumbass yeah
okay but it's it's 50 style that's the
way it was that's the way it went it's
kind of like an immersive
experience of [ __ ] listening to these
dudes tell you that we're going to fight
these ants we're going to save the earth
you know it's it's good it's it's good
um i'd say it's up there with war of the
worlds
yeah and i mean i don't think anyone's
going to argue with you i mean anytime
anybody is talking about 50s creature
features 50s sci-fi movies this is
always like in the top 10 somewhere and
it's pretty easy to see why like i said
i kind of feel like a lot of the big bug
movies that came in the wake of this
like tarantula or the deadly mantis or
something like that
which were okay
but they were like rip-offs of this the
thing that makes this one work i think
is not only did they build you know
three big [ __ ] ants that are so it's
not just like a tarantula crawling
across a postcard or whatever the [ __ ]
like they did like with process shots
like some of the other ones yeah they
they actually built i think they built
three whole ones okay and then like
parts of other ones like for various
shots although it looks like they built
a lot more than that but that was like
clever editing but i think what makes
this one really good is one
the characters are all really distinct
from one another it's just not just a
bunch of like generic hero white dudes
who can't really tell apart
and the writing in this is really good
yeah everything in this
makes logical sense and follows from the
thing that came before the movie lays
out clearly what its rules are it
follows its own rules
and the way that it goes like the first
third of it is probably like is set up
like a mystery or like an investigation
because you never see the answer because
you don't see the ants until probably
like a third it's not a hugely long
movie it's only like an hour and a half
but yeah you don't see them you're just
seeing it from the point of view of like
people investigating like what the [ __ ]
is going on so it's like a mixture
you'll know it's yeah and so then when
after they discover it and then when
they get to the halfway point i really
like that the stakes keep increasing
because they get to the halfway point
they find the nest and they are like
okay what are we gonna do about this and
they figure it out and then they think
they destroyed the nest but no
then like the stakes are raised again
because they're like okay well we
destroyed all these ants but two of the
queens escaped
with drones and we have to figure out
where they went because they're going to
establish you know more nests elsewhere
and they're going to wipe out the human
race eventually if they keep doing that
so then like after that they pivot to
another mystery where they're trying to
figure out like where the queens went to
so they can destroy it before you know
it kind of like then there's an
escalator then there's a theme of opsec
or operational security where they're
trying to keep the [ __ ]
uh quiet they don't want to panic
the population then eventually they're
like no we have to tell people so they
had that thing going too there's one
part where a guy sees the drones flying
in his airplane in his cessna and he's
all world war ii pilot and he says they
were ufos that looked like ants and they
went and they they kept his ass locked
up because they didn't want him going
around uh
they knew he was telling the truth but
they said no he's crazy keep him locked
yeah keep him in here until like so he
doesn't like that
which is that was some more operational
security stuff so it's kind of like
there's a theme of hey you know the
government does [ __ ] that's crooked to
protect other people in the big picture
so i like that that aspect that would
you know who that was that was playing
that one it was one scene but he was he
made a big impression um that was fess
parker he actually went on later to be
davey crockett
in the original davy crockett show like
the disney one and he was daniel boone
also okay and matter of fact it was this
movie like disney executives like saw
him in this movie and were like oh that
guy should play davy crockett yeah uh so
yeah so he made a big impression he was
actually great in this there is like
humor in this yeah but you know the
drunks in particular talk about the
drunken
rocks a lot of drunk humor good though i
like the trunks yeah they made me laugh
out loud a few times yeah so i like that
but
i like that the movie isn't because some
of the like cheesier 50s big bug movies
or big monster movies i kind of feel
like they were almost i don't want to
say that they were like self-aware or
they were like winking at the audience
but i kind of feel like
i i kind of feel like it was a little
bit more in that direction this one
takes itself pretty seriously it's not
like all the actors are good they're not
like making a joke out of it's like oh
giant ants you know what i mean it's
like everybody's like oh [ __ ] because
look you know in real life if ants grew
to this size we would be hosed big time
and they kind of go into that in this
movie what i liked about it is that this
is definitely post world war ii
most of the guys in this movie are cops
or soldiers or scientists and they've
all been through the war they talk about
it even the dude who saw the flying ufo
ants was from the war
so because it's a post-war movie
it's
it's trying to make it's taking itself
seriously and it's trying to increase
the badass level everything in it they
can't
they can't be fake
okay everything in it looks authentic
uh those authentic uniforms authentic
equipment the way they're wearing their
gears good and it is correct for the
time
um they're not they're they're they're
they're homage in the military very much
is very much kind of kind of a
a movie that veterans would go see i
could tell i would have loved this if i
was a world war ii vet
uh and what what this translates to
is believability in certain within with
its believability within the limitations
of the special effects of the time
the the action scenes with the guns are
the best i've seen in the 50s
remember him when he was down there
surrounded by all those ants and machine
gun on them and stuff just the way it
was shot the cinematography the editing
and everything it was
it was very high action and then the
[ __ ] so his buddies eventually bust
through the wall
and and pull him out of there and save
him
you didn't normally see good fight
choreography in in 50 [ __ ] it's usually
like blame real lame yeah but this was
like
like something out of aliens you know
with the colonial marines fighting the
aliens down inside the reactor and
everything
you can tell that that is homaging this
yeah because some of the scenes
particularly when they get out of here
when they have to go down because like i
said when they find the first nest which
is supposed to be like in the new mexico
desert it's actually shot in california
but you know it's supposed to be new
mexico and they find the first nest and
they're like okay well
what we're gonna do is we're gonna use
the bazookas and we're gonna lay down
like a layer of this like phosphorus and
that'll keep them down because they
don't like the heat and it'll keep them
down in there and then we can like get
real close and throw a bunch of cyanide
gas in there and gas them all out and
like i said this does work to an extent
but they're like yeah but now we have to
go down in there and make sure they're
all dead because the doctor is like yeah
if some of the queens escaped then we're
[ __ ] and like they'll build other
nests elsewhere so we have to go down
there and make sure everyone's dead yeah
it was a woman yeah it was a woman she a
woman scientist she insisted go down
go down there and the guys are trying to
protect her you know because this is
they're they're they're being what you
call back in the day hard-boiled you
know they're they're kind of hardcore
these are tough guys you know what i
mean military uh veterans from world war
ii and they're like no it's too
dangerous for a woman she gets down
there and kicks ass though she's like
[ __ ] i'm a sign i'm a scientist
she's like you guys don't know what to
look for like i know what to look for so
i'm going so like plus i just met you
yesterday don't tell me right yeah
there's a lot of
some of that [ __ ] going on well i guess
these women can also do hard course
so it's pretty good it's good it's good
yeah there is a little bit of the like
oh ladies
i'm going to get sick so i can bubble up
there is a little bit of that but it's
not i've seen like a lot worse yeah it's
not maybe and she is like a very serious
character she knows her [ __ ] it's her
well she's good looking too so yeah i
mean she's actually she started as an
opera singer actually
uh you know that that actress uh joan
welding her name is and uh so when they
came there
like because
they come there because i guess like the
fbi were kind of like we can't figure
out like what this uh because before
they even see the ants they don't know
it's ants but like they find these like
footprints they're like what the [ __ ]
are these and so they send them to like
the fbi like field lab but they're like
we don't know what the [ __ ] this is they
kick it to like
a zoologist or something like that and
so they so the fbi actually ends up
sending
this uh the two doctors who's like it's
like this daughtering old dude who's
also like a genius and his daughter and
they're both like they work together
kind of like entomologist types yeah i
like you know what i really liked i
really liked that the dad
he didn't um i don't think he ever
called his daughter by her name which i
think was patricia he always called her
doctor and i was like that's pretty
awesome yeah he always he had like a lot
of respect and they were always like
talking to each other like well what are
we going to do well everything was going
on
it was all professional i thought that
was that was a nice touch yeah i liked
that very much but yeah so the guy that
played the older doctor was actually
edmond gwen who is the same guy that
played uh kris kringle in miracle on
34th street so there you go
i was pretty sure i had seen that little
girl that was in this because
i love
love the first
act of this
like i said if you know everybody knows
this came out like a long time ago and
so everybody now knows that uh obviously
this giant ants but the way that they
kind of and you probably back then you
would have known it was giant because
the shit's on the poster yeah so but i
like that the first third of it they lay
it out as though
you know the cops or whatever are like
they have no idea what the [ __ ] this is
so they laying out like a mystery like
in the first thing is they're going
around in the plane or something like
that and they see a little girl yeah
with a broken doll yep walking through
the desert by herself like and she looks
like all [ __ ] up like she's in shock
she's just like well i don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm gonna know she's like
walking through and they're like trying
to like hey little girl like who are you
and she won't answer them and she's like
in shock
and you said that's that was newt that's
where they got yeah that's where they
got the issues and she's very new she's
very very proto-nude yeah
and then like the two cops and then you
go through the the two police
investigations one of those guys gets
killed the other one he ends up being
basically
the hero of the story um he eventually
ends up giving his life to save the kids
didn't he wasn't that he does yeah
because when they go down because they
like i said they destroy the first nest
but when they get down there they
discover that the queens have escaped so
then they have to like spend like the
second and third act of the movie like
finding out where the queens went to
and it turns out that the queen had
established another nest
underneath like in the um storm drains
like underneath los angeles and so they
have to go down in there and you know
destroy everything and there's two
little kids to make it like extra tense
yeah um there were two little kids and
their dad and they were down in the
storm drains like flying model airplanes
or something like that and the ants
attacked them and killed the dad but
they don't know if the kids are are dead
or if they're still in there so they
have to kind of go in there and
one thing that got me with the movie is
that the cops you know they were they
were ex-military
then they hook up with the general and
then a little later on they're all back
in their military uniform so i don't
know if he reactivated them or what he
was
they had
they were back in their army uniforms
and the and the the general giving them
bazookas they were part of the damn
mission to blow up the damn first nest
out in the they never really explained
that
yeah i'm not really sure like i mean you
know whatever cops are not in the army
i know but i mean if they were veterans
maybe they could have said maybe
somebody had the authority to like put
them back on duty because of the
situation this emergency situation or
something
they just put they just put surplus
equipment on or just got issued an
emergency issue yeah they probably
they're just like look we got a big
problem and we need all the dudes we're
[ __ ] reactivated right like i kind of
figured that out maybe they were
national guard too
yeah so yeah so there are like lots of
avenues where they could have like done
that right
so yeah so i want to kind of go into a
little bit um like i said there's a [ __ ]
ton of people i brought up like james
whitmore who plays uh ben who's kind of
like the hero of the movie he's one of
the first cops that investigates uh and
his partner gets killed like early on
like they find like the trailer that's
all busted out and like sugar and they
find like the grocer dead and all this
other kind of stuff that guy was in a
[ __ ] ton of stuff and i knew i'd like he
was in oklahoma he was in torah torah
torah actually uh probably younger
people will recognize him from the
shawshank redemption he played like the
old guy brooks in that movie that was
one of his last roles
um and also james arness is in this who
was in a [ __ ] ton of movies including uh
the original thing from another world
from 1951 but probably best known as
marshall matt dillon on gunsmoke uh who
he was on there for 20 years actually
also peter graves's older brother in
case you didn't know that
so the movie the original story for this
movie
um it was by a guy named george worthing
yates and i knew i knew that name i was
like he must have written a [ __ ] on
the stuff that was on mst he did uh
earth versus flying saucers amazing
colossal man the one about the big giant
dude uh earth versus spider wore the
colossal bees king kong versus godzilla
tormented uh a bunch a whole bunch of
other ones now apparently i think it was
him but he got the idea i guess he had
seen was so horrified by the atomic bomb
like it was dropped on uh hiroshima
that he wanted to make
something to
sort of like a movie about this is what
happens when we [ __ ] around with this
kind of [ __ ] you know what i mean like
we get giant ants and we're gonna wipe
out the human race like i said this
wasn't the first like anti-nuclear kind
of like or you know what what have we
wrought type of thing that was you know
there had been a couple prior to that
but this was the first one that was bugs
he also and i was watching another video
about this earlier i guess around the
time that he was writing this there was
this line of like flower seeds i don't
know if they were like carnations or
marigolds or something like that and
they made a
the big advertising selling point was
like we bombarded this with x-rays
and so they would grow the flowers and
the flowers were like really big they
were like a foot across or some [ __ ] so
he had seen that because they were
really popular and he's just like holy
crap like what would happen if it could
make the flowers that big then what
would it do to like other animals you
know what i mean so that's how he got
the idea so he writes the screenplay it
goes through a couple iterations and
originally this is really weird but
warner brothers were gonna make it
but then like the executives were like
well we kind of think like giant ants
that's kind of stupid um they weren't
they didn't really get sci-fi even
though beasts from twenty 000 fathoms
like the year before had been like
wildly successful like with the ray
harry housing creature and stuff
um but they were just kind of like i
don't know if we want to do it i don't
know if we want to do this so they were
so reluctant that they offered to sell
the script to i think it was 20th
century fox
20th century fox were like yeah we'll
take it uh we'll give you half a million
dollars yeah at which point warner
brothers is like never mind we'll keep
it you know what i mean because they
didn't realize like how valuable the
property was that they had i guess
so they decided to make it now
originally it was going to be in color
and in 3d that would have been great
probably so you can see like that some
of the scenes like to like that uh
toward the end like with the
flamethrowers being shot right at the
camera yeah they've been good and
there's like a couple of others where
you can tell that it was kind of shot
for 3d originally but then i guess like
the technology didn't work out or they
didn't really like it and then like
again they even though you know 20th
century fox had wanted it warner
brothers still seemed like they weren't
real
sure about the concept and so like
literally i think two days before they
started shooting it they're like never
mind we're not doing it in color do it
in black and white uh and they also
didn't do it widescreen did you notice
that
it's in like it's in uh i think it's in
four three like aspects maybe the ants
didn't look as good in color maybe they
looked real fake actually from
everything
everything i've heard they actually
looked better in the color um because
they they said when they painted them
like i said they made three full grown
ones they painted them like this purpley
green and it's they said it looked like
you know like an ants you know
exoskeleton like it was kind of shiny
okay and they said it looked really good
in color like when they did the test
prints and stuff like that but i think
warner brothers just wanted to cheap out
black and white was cheaper
yeah and um you know i was watching it
going but i'd like to see a colorized
version you did say that yeah colorized
version i didn't know you could probably
restore it
yeah i wonder if remember when ted
turner was colorizing everything back in
the day i wonder if he ever colorized
this one i don't really know
but yeah it was originally supposed to
be in color but then they decided they
were going to cheap out and just do it
in black and white but honestly i mean
it's still good in black and white and i
think some of the scenes like where like
i said where they're creeping around
down in the uh down in the storm drains
or where they're down in the nest and
stuff like that are like actually really
creepy
um and maybe would have suffered from
being a color i'm not really entirely
sure but they do have it's interesting
because the the title like when it comes
up them you know what i mean uh the
title is in color
but they did that like just specifically
like they were like hey it was gonna be
in color but now this is all that's left
like just the title being at the time i
was watching it the only thing that i
that that i was like man i wish they
would have done this and that is uh when
the
pilot is saying that he saw ufos that
looked like ants yeah there should have
been a little scene where you know
flashback of what that way he's not just
telling the story you actually see what
he's seeing because they could have
easily done that i just don't know why
they did i mean well i kind of feel like
because the budget was cut um maybe and
i don't know if this is true i'm just
speculating but maybe they were gonna
have a flashback but they're like we
can't really afford to have like three
because he saw three of them right or
four of them three i think you said
three like one it was a queen and two of
the drones yeah so like flying through
the air so maybe that would have been or
maybe they didn't it didn't look that
good or something like that another
thing that i noticed too that was
probably budgetary was that if you
notice like two of the queens escaped
right
one of the queens went and uh made a
nest on that like it was an aircraft
carrier right yeah but they didn't show
that they just had them like talking
about it yeah and they're like yeah we
had to sync that [ __ ] because you know
because the nest was on there and so but
they didn't show it and i said well
that's probably because it would have
been too expensive to show because
mostly they just go after the the other
queen
that ends up like underneath so that was
something that i thought of when i was
watching it i was like oh they didn't
they just showed them in a board room
saying well we found one of them and it
was on an aircraft carrier and we sunk
the [ __ ] so that one's taken care of but
then yeah they end up in the la flood
control system where i used to play as a
kid yeah and i was i was having
flashbacks i was going yeah yeah i
remember i think i kind of knew where
that was i think that was i think that
was over there near uh
near where uh
the old barn was i think it was i think
it was in alameda or near alameda anyway
it's hard to tell a lot of that [ __ ]
looks the same on wikipedia it says uh
between the first and seventh street
bridges east of downtown los angeles all
right so no no okay it's closer it's
that's where they shot yeah
i was watching that we used we used to
try to go in there and we'd make damn
torches yeah i was about ten you know
eight and eight nine ten we'd make
torches and try to go into those things
and we'd get as soon as it started to
get dark we'd get too chicken and back
we and we never took flashlights always
tried to make a torch because we uh
thought we were cave man
yeah and we were afraid of those ants we
thought those ants might be down in
there we'd seen this movie i mean you
never know yeah
i think originally they were going to
shoot the the climax like on the santa
monica pier but i guess it was like too
expensive now now during that during
that sequence where the army is going
through the storm drains
uh
you can tell that it's authentic yeah
they really went out of there and
vehicles and that they're really in
there
and uh that
those dudes look like army rangers to me
they weren't
actors they were
uh those dudes were that was top-notch
top-notch infantry dudes
for the 50s you know they were
you know
[ __ ] buffed out for the 50s 50s a lot
of guys were [ __ ] weedy in the 50s
they're pretty big dudes
and um
good equipment the way they're wearing
their kit is good the correct boots
um they had m1 garands with rifle
grenades on the end they were shooting
those dance
guys with m1 thompson's m1a1 or the
thompson's a1s
from world war ii
real flame throwers
yeah lots of flamethrowers yeah
lots of fire dirty car beats
shooting fire at the big hands it's
awesome 30 carbines and really the best
fight choreography of the 50s
it was that final scene
close yeah i mean that's really it yeah
because they're in the clu and then like
there's like cave-ins and like all the
ants are coming at them and they're like
shooting fire we get separated from
everybody else and he's trying to save
himself from all his dance and he's
machine gunning them up close you know
he just barely made it and then they
finally bust through the wall and come
in and shoot them all up and they all
they all get out of there it was just
good choreography the edit was right it
was just like something out of them
aliens
i like to at the end that because i kind
of feel like a lot of 50s movies came in
the wake of this
um and i'm thinking here what was the
one about the about the crickets
beginning at the end um yeah where it's
just like well we have to uh you know
capture one of these things for science
or anything like that like at the end of
this everybody was just like nope burn
them up yeah
no thank you we're not having any more
of that
so they just like burn them all up at
the end also uh oh a couple fun facts
uh did you notice
that leonard nimoy
uh has a very very small like walk-on
role no no
very very young i think he i think he
has had a couple of lines but he was um
do you know the scene where
uh they were saying okay well we're
trying to we don't want to tell the
public what's going on because they'll
freak out but we so any time that you
hear any like kind of weird because
they're trying to figure out like where
the queen went to so they're like well
any time you hear any like ufo sightings
or anything like that like send it to
our office so we can like track where
the [ __ ] is and there's a scene where
there's a call that comes in about the
ufo thing and leonard nimoy is the
officer that takes it and then hands the
the thing over to the girl that's like
at the desk
and he says something to her about it
like oh this crazy [ __ ] and she's like
what are the what are they doing up
there or something like that because
they don't know so yeah that's leonard
nimoy um i don't know if this was his
first screen appearance but uh yeah man
now now that i know that that this was
the cheap version that there was going
to be an expensive version it was color
i wish they would have made that one
yeah i wish they would have made that
you know the special effects for this
got nominated for an oscar that year i
see it didn't win 20 000 leagues under
the sea did but it did um then when you
said that those ants looked even better
in color that's what i heard i don't
know like i haven't seen them but that's
what everybody that was there said they
looked a lot better because they were
like this purpley green like shiny yeah
in the black and white version they look
okay yeah they look good it was a lot
better than the 50s
than your average [ __ ] of the 50s
you know it just symbolizes the ant
but uh they
they don't look real to me
no they don't they look cool though but
i bet you they would have looked a lot
better in color yeah i mean obviously
you can tell they're mechanical and like
that somebody's back there but like i
said it's always i it's gonna look a lot
better than what i said again i'm gonna
bring up beginning of the end where the
crickets are attacking chicago at the
end and it's very very clearly a
postcard with regular-sized crickets
yeah crawling up they're going off into
the sky
you know stupid so it looks like a lot
better than that and even like to movies
like tarantula and earth versus the
spider they used like real spiders but
it was like a process shot so you'd like
blow it up and like put the you know you
you'd lay the spider like overnight over
the even though
it still doesn't matter the ant is fake
but the dude is in frame with it and
he's interacting with it it's an object
that's really there that's always more
exciting i like that better and i liked
that the ants like they had like the big
mandibles yeah and they would grab like
some dudes and i'd be like man how
[ __ ] [ __ ] would you be if that
happened and well the one guy like the
grocer that gets killed gramps like near
the beginning before they know that it's
ants
you know the the guy doing the autopsy
is like [ __ ] we don't know what
happened to this guy because it's like
his [ __ ] spine's broken and his
head's broken and his neck's broken and
like he's [ __ ] broken they find a
piece of an ant like of chitin i guess
got shot off by a 38 revolver that was
laying there on the ground they never
could find i think gramps might have
done that they took it but they never
did say what it was did they
when did what what are you talking about
when they were going through the trailer
and i was either that wasn't a piece of
an aunt that was that was the broken off
piece of the little girl doll
that's how they knew that the little
girl had come from that trailer because
they're like oh that was the piece of
the of the doll's head that was broken
off because they had the scene at the
end where she was sleeping in the car
and he brought it back and like put it
on the on the girls that's yeah because
they didn't know they found the girl
wandering in the desert and she wouldn't
talk and so then they were like okay
well we found a trailer up here that's
all [ __ ] up that looks like somebody
went in there like busted out the side
and everybody's gone and that's how they
knew that she had come from that trailer
because they found and i think they
found like a little piece of fabric from
her robe and stuff too so there's that
not a perfect movie but an enjoyable
movie and
and for the 50s great
great it's up there with like war of the
worlds
forbidden planet
yeah i mean definitely if you're into
50s movies 50s sci-fi this is one of the
ones this is like one of the
quintessential like 50s sci-fi movies
you have to see the first big bug
movie and honestly i would say probably
the best one
um you know because oh big movies
and i think like a lot of that is
because of the characters because of the
storytelling i just really liked all the
characters in this i liked like i said i
i feel like later ones you just kind of
have this panoply of like
white dudes
with square jaws and like big suits and
they all kind of like were
indistinguishable from one another
whereas in this one
it seemed like they all had their own
distinct personalities they all had
their distant character i really i
particularly really liked like the old
doctor guy like he was great because he
was like so doddering but he was clearly
a genius
but like he wasn't daughtering he was
just kind of like so in his own head
that he didn't really have time for all
of this nonsense like the funny scene
where they're in the helicopter and
they're telling him well you have to say
when you're done talking like over the
thing you have to say over he's like why
they know i'm done talking and he's like
why do we have to do this is ridiculous
we don't have like time to waste on this
[ __ ] and i was like i agree with you
man i agree so he like gets all crazy
he was like look they know that it's me
okay we also found out that back in the
50s when la was a [ __ ] was a
civilization they had [ __ ] hospitals
for drunk people
the drunk ward the drunk war i was like
who knew and it's just bands with drunk
dudes in there
they said that one dude had been the one
dude that's like make me a sergeant
bring me the booze that guy that was
like singing they said that guy had been
there for five months
and i was like holy cow did he and he
didn't even know that he was in there
well he was the guy that knew
like he was yeah he wasn't just like a
random dude he was he they uh were
talking to him because he said he'd seen
the ants going down into the thing but
he was so drunk that nobody listened to
him because everyone just thought he was
a loon but i just thought yeah there are
like lots of funny drunks in this yeah i
just think that's and i was just like
the whole time and it's like let's go to
like the drunk way i'm like the hospital
is a drunk ward yeah holy [ __ ] the hero
the hero says
heroes they're saying make sure that
those ants are all get saturated there's
something something that said some kind
of poison and he goes i'm gonna get
saturated
[Laughter]
that's so great it's just so evocative i
love it this movie too also another fun
fact for for you film buffs out there
has two uses of the infamous wilhelm
scream yeah uh actually maybe three i
heard it twice but this but you have to
think that it wasn't like a cliche back
then because i think it had only started
being used like in the early 50s like
maybe 51 52. the stock screen it's a
stock screen yeah and it's very i'll put
it in i'll put it in the uh the video
like right here
right there um you know what i mean so
but yeah i mean everybody knows what it
is it's like a very very classic noise
but it's just funny to hear it because
now
you know everybody knows what the
wilhelm scream sounds like but it was
funny
for me to like watch the movie and i was
like hey wilhelm cream then i was like
later on i was like oh another one like
one of the guys like when got grabbed by
the mandibles like he did the wilhelm
scream and i just thought that was
really funny so i thought that would
point that out i think somebody else
that showed up i was gonna say when
leonard nimoy you know is in this dick
york is supposedly in this too but i
didn't see him like i don't think he had
any speaking letters or anything like
that but he's uh dick
from uh i dream of jeannie oh okay yeah
yeah yeah um i yeah he was supposedly in
this too like but i guess it was like a
blink and you'll miss it type of uh
walk-on type of thing but leonard nimoy
had a lot at least one line i remember
like talking to that girl at the desk
but he yeah he's like super young in
this and he's in a uniform and
everything like that but yeah like ever
like i said if you're into like creature
features at all if you're into sci-fi at
all definitely see this one if only
because of how
influential it was like you said aliens
directly homages several scenes from
this movie so does alien yeah that's one
of them from alien yeah dallas going
through the two going through the
tunnels with the yeah because that
happens at the end of this like i said
the whole thing about the little girl
with the doll and then finding her not
being able to talk because something
dramatic happened and yeah all that
stuff um you know that's directly from
this movie woman going down there
looking for the egg cases and with the
queen where the queen lived that's in it
she's got two dudes with her but that's
all there and she goes back ah bad news
that queen hatched it's not here yeah
we're like [ __ ] now we're [ __ ] how
funny would it have been like in the 50s
movie if that if that lady doctor had
just said let go of her you [ __ ]
that would have been hilarious but yeah
that doesn't happen but something maybe
somebody could do a fan at it just yeah
i'm still going to go back and say uh in
the final and at the end of the movie in
the final action scene some of the best
action sequences i've seen in in a 50s
movie yeah
i mean it's definitely stands the taste
of time i mean
and now i find out that there was a
color version and this is a cheap
version they were going to make it they
were going to make it even more
expensive man i wish they would have
made that one
i wonder how much if because this movie
was like a big hit like i said it was
kind of one of their it was easily one
of warner brothers like biggest earners
that year and i kind of wonder would it
have done even better probably like if
it had been color in 3d like they
originally
did with with the extra action scenes
that weren't included yeah i know it
would have been great yeah it would have
been great but it's still great the way
it is i mean honestly but i would like
to kind of see that
version right but yeah so
i want to see the full boat version yeah
it would have been probably it would
have been better
i wonder they've never they've never
remade this have they no you could
remake this
if i were to ever remake this it would
be a period piece it'd be happened in
the 50s it only makes sense if it's
happening in the 50s yeah i think they
definitely shouldn't make it like said
in the 50s like so it would have the
same same like a toast war because the
ants in case we didn't mention it were
caused by
radiation from alamogordo
you know from the atomic bomb test them
was also homaged in um the fallout video
game series yeah fallout 3. don't don't
well don't they have big ants in there
that'll call those those or something
there's a side mission you can get
involved in and you have to [ __ ]
destroy the ants and it's right out of
the right it's it's them yeah yeah i
mean that's hilarious but yeah seriously
uh it's really good
watch it whether you're under 50 [ __ ] or
not it's just like a really entertaining
uh easily one of the best movies from
the 1950s uh so yeah it's on amazon
prime i think it was 3.99 to rent it so
check it out or if you've seen it if you
haven't seen it in a long time let us
know in the comments what you think
about it and that'll do it for this
movie retrospective we will see you guys
on the next one bye